[موسيقى]
لطالما عانت المناطق النائيه في بلدان
العربيه من التهميش وغياب فرص العمل
والتنميه رغم اني بعضها بموارد طبيعيه
وبشريه ولا طالما رصدت الموازنه والمشاريع
لفك العزله عن الاطراف لكن المركز ظل
يستاثر بالنصيب الاكبر من الفرص مما تسبب
في بعض البلدان بموجات النزوح جماعيه لا
تزال مستمره منذ عقود مما افقد العواصم
العربيه
ولا هم قادرون على العوده الى مناطقم
الاصليه التي لم تنل نصيبها من التنميه
والتطوير فالمشاريع التنمويه تقل او تتاجل
حتى لو اقررت والبطانه والفقر سنتان
غالبتان رغم ثروات هذه المناطق نتناول في
قصتنا امثله لهذه مستقل مهمشه في ولايه
تانجاند في صحراء موريتانيا وسيدي بوزيد
في تونس ولايه البحر الاحمر شرق السودان
التي تشتركوا جميعها في ضعف التنميه
والانفاق العام وتدني مستوى التعليم
والصحه
اسباب الظاهره ومعاناه اهالي هذه المناطق
وكيفيه التعامل الحكومات معها نستكمل بقيه
قصتنا مع ضيفنا الدكتوره داليا غانم باحثه
اولى مقيمه في مركز
الشرق الاوسط والدكتور فارس بريزات الوزير
السابق ومدير مركز للاستشارات
الاستراتيجيه نحاول مع ضيفين الكريمين فصل
الواقع الاوسع لمثل هذه المناطق المهمشه
في عالمنا العربيه هل تجاهلها كان مقصودا
اما انه افراز لتحديات اقتصاديه وجغرافيه
وسياسيه نتسائل عن تداعيات استمرار هذه
الظاهره ومدى نجاعه السياسات المعلنه
لمعالجه الاختلالات التنمويه في الدول
العربيه نبدا الحوار هذا مو شباب مشاهده
القصه
[موسيقى]
يوصف اقليم الجاهلي والمراد والفقر
[تصفيق]
عملت الاستاذ
[موسيقى]
رغم ان ممارسات الاقصاء والتهميش نحو بعض
الجماعات والمناطق ظاهره عالميه قديمه لكن
تسليط الضوء عليها بدا يتصاعد في
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي حيث اطلق
الاختصاصي الاجتماعيه الفرنسي الروني
لونوار مصطلح ضحايا الاقصائي على هذه
الظاهره في العالم العربي تظهر مؤشرات
الامم المتحده نسقا تنمويا متبينا يضع بعض
الدول في ذيل القائمه وبعضها في المقدمه
لكن التنميه المستدامه داخل هذه الدول
تواجه عوائقه هيكليه تكاد تكون نفسها في
كل الدول رغم اختلاف مستويات الدخل
والموارد بحسب التقرير العربي للتنميه
الصادريه عن الامم المتحده هذا التباين
وافرز مناطق مهمشه اسفر عن تحديات
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وثقافيه في تلك الدول
جهات الغير حاضره في السلطه يكون
عندها ظروف مواتيه
وبالتالي انتشار السياسي والاجتماعي
والاقتصادي والثقافي من خلال السياسات
الاجتماعيه
[تصفيق]
الا نستطيع ان نقول بان هنالك التهميش
قصدي هنالك قصور في التنميه هنالك قصور في
الخدمات قد تكون الامكانيات متوفره ولكن
الاضطراب السياسي هو تسبب الاساسي في عدم
انتشار التنميه صعوبه المواصلات عقيدات
الجغرافيا كل ذلك يجعل من المناطق الطرفيه
هي الاكثر من حيث عدم التنميه ومن حيث عدم
الاستقرار ومن حيث عدم توفر الخدمات
[موسيقى]
تحدد الامم المتحده مسارات التهميش
والتنميه في الدول بقياس مؤشرات الفقر
والاميه وتوفر المياه والطعام والبنيه
التحتيه والمشاركه السياسيه والخدمات
الصحيه والبطاله والمشاريع المستدامه غياب
الاحصاءات الرسميه العربيه حول حجم
الانفاق بين المدن ليحول دون معرفه حجم
التباين التنموي الحقيقي بين مناطق الدوله
الواحده
تتبعنا واقعه ثلاث مناطق عربيه كامثله
لظاهره التهمش فمن ولايه تيجانيت في صحراء
موريتانيا الى ولايه البحر الاحمر شرق
السودان مرورا بمدينه سيدي بوزيد وسط تونس
تشتركوا هذه المناطق في ضعف التنميه
والانفاق وتدني مستوى التعليم والصحه
وهجره سكانها مقارنه بمدن اخرى في ذات
الدوله
[موسيقى]
كذلك هذه المناطق صارت نوع من مناطق طارده
للسكان في ظل عدم وجود بدائل خاصه للشباب
همم المتعلم هو مضطر انه يذهب الى الحواضر
الى المدن الكبيره كي يشتغل
هذا له تاثير مباشر على على الساكنه يظهر
في عدم الولوج للخدمات الاساسيه مثل
التعليم والصحه والخدمات العامه بهدايه
يؤثر مباشره على حياتهم
هذه الازمات الكبيره جدا ان تكون هنالك
موارد متوفره وان تكون السلطات والقيادات
والمجتمع والنخبه ليس لهم مقدر على
الاستفاده من هذه الموارد
في السودان تصنف ولايه البحر الاحمر شرق
البلاد كاكثر المناطق تهميشا رغم امتلاكها
موقعا بحريا استراتيجيا يحتضن الموانئ
ومواقع التعدين والذهاب السكان المحليون
يعانون من ترد الخدمات والتعليم وانتشار
الامراض والاوبئه وتدني فرص العمل بحسب
بيانات المجلس الاستشاري لشرق السودان
التي اظهرت ايضا تجاوز نسبه الفقر لاربعه
واربعون بالمائه اعلى نسبه بين ولايات
البلاد
رواتب الشهريه لا تكفي لحاجه ايا ايار
منزل او ايجار شقه بما
انها هفره يعني مصانع الاسمنت الان توجد
في السودان هي توجد خارج اقليم شرق
السودان بما ان الماده الاساسيه اللي ممكن
يتعامل بها ماده الاسمنت هي ماده الجير هي
ام لا توجد الا في شرق السودان
[موسيقى]
انا اشتغلت مره تدريب في مدرسه كان مثلا
المدرسه اللي انا اشتغلت فوق تدريب
الاكتزاز بتاعه طلاب يعني الفصل مثلا
فوقها في فصل من الفصول في مدارس مكتزه
المعلمين ثمانيه سته سبعه ترجع مثلا بتاع
الرياضيات
السودان من المناطق القابله للانفجار وقد
يهدد استقرار الدوله السودانيه وشرق
السودان قد يؤدي الى احداث انقسامات داخل
الدوله السودانيه شبيهه بما حدث عام 2005
بانفصال جنوب السودان
[موسيقى]
التي اقرت لكنها لم تنفذ بتوثيقا من
تقارير محليه ودوليه صندوق تنميه شرق
السودان ومشروع استجرار مياه الشرب ومشروع
مكافحه مرض السل الذي اوقفته الحكومه
واستبدلته بمشروع التعليم مقابل الغذاء
المعطل بدوره حتى اليوم قصور تبرره
الحكومه الحاليه بما تسميه فساد النظام
السابق وتقول انها بدات بخطوات اصلاحيه
[موسيقى]
تم افقار مقصود حقيقه لمنطقه اقليم
السودان وتم حتى نهب هذه الثروات وتجيره
لصالح النافذين في نظام المؤتمر الوطني
الذي حكم السودان 30 عام حتى نستطيع ان
نعمل تنميه شامله لابد ان تبدا خطوات
بتهيئه
المناخ وتهيه الارض على ارض الواقع ولذلك
كان لابد من تفكيك النظام الاستبدادي
ابتداء عبر 16 مهمه همم وضعت في الوثيقه
الدستوريه حتى تهيا الاجواء فعلا
شركه الكوري المعروفه عالميا لشركه تنين
كان بتعمل في الغزل والنسيج كانت موجوده
في ولايه البحر الاحمر اا ثم
ايقاف الشركه دي شركه الاطارات كانت
موجوده وبرضو تم ايقافه فهذه المسائل كلها
هي مسائل مقصوده يعني صح هذه شبههم معدومه
يعني اي اي حاله يعني ممكن
تنتقل الى الخرطوم ولا الى جهاد اخرى
مع توفر كل العوامل العوامل الجغرافيه
والعوامل الاقتصاديه في ظل التخلف قائم
يظل تظل الامراض مسيطره تظل النزاعات
القبليه قائمه يظل الشرق السودان على ما
هو عليه
[موسيقى]
في موريتانيا تظهر تقارير صحفيه محليه
واحصاءات دوليه تفاوتا جليا في التنميه
بين ولاياتها 13 على بعد 600 كيلو متر عن
العاصمه واكشوط تقع ولايه تجاره التي تزيد
مساحتها عن 95,000 كلم مربع فالضعف بنيتها
التحتيه فضلا عن قصور في الخدمات الاساسيه
وعزوف المدرسين عن الالتحاق بمدارسها
عوامل وضعتها في خانه اكثر ولايات البلاد
تمشا
[موسيقى]
اعيش في هذه المدينه التي تعتبر مدينه
معزوله في عزله التجاريه تضاريس المنطقه
والنتيجه ل ااا بعدها عن مركز عاصمه
المدينه افكر بشكل جدي في الهجره عن
المدينه نتيجه لضعف الخدمات
يعود الانسان يصبح في هم الوحيد للحصول
الى المياه
المتردد خدمات التعليم
[موسيقى]
ما باقي حد ما يعرف انه مهمشين بعدها
نلتقي معتمده الدوله كامله
[موسيقى]
الحكومه الحاليه لا تهمش تقانتك ولايه
الناس استفاده من برامج الدوله في السنوات
الثنتين الاخيره برامج التامين الصحي
برامج
[موسيقى]
تقسيم
نقدي ساهمت بتخفيف
الوضعيه اللي يعيش المواطن واحنا طبعا
بصدد برامج اخرى برامج
داخل الساكنه همم عن طريق البرنامج
[موسيقى]
تضم ولايه تيجانيت اكثر من 600 الف نخله
تشكل اساس اقتصادها ومصدر رزق الاهالي لكن
تعطل مشروع الواحات ومشاريع سقايه التي
وعدت بها الحكومه سارع من زحف الصحراء
والى جانب هذه التهديدات بالحسار واحات
النخيل فاقم الحديث عن نقل مشروع جامعه
الى ولايه اخرى من احباط السكان
الشعله من الحكومه بان السكان بان يرحلوا
عن المدينه لان كانوا يعلقون اعمال كبيره
جدا على الجامعه التي سوف تضرب
الخدمات وتفرض عوده الناس الى المدينه
وبالتالي مشكله خيبه امل الكثيرين
التي كانت عليها اعتماد
في حياتهم بشكل عام وقد ايه وهجره اغلى
بيت الشباب
نحن نعمل بجد على مقاومه
العوامل المناخيه الطارق على الواحه وحتى
انا فكرنا واحنا الان في تجربه انواع اخرى
في تونس تعد ولايات القصرين وسيدي بوزيد
والقيروان اكثر المناطق تهميشا حسب تقارير
منظمات المجتمع المدني والمعهد الوطني
للاحصاء
تتبعنا واقعه مدينه سيدي بوزيد التي تعاني
من قصور في المرافق الصحيه وضعف الربط
الطرقي ووعوره في المسالك الزراعيه التي
تؤثر على الفلاحين وانتاجهم الزراعي حيث
تقول الحكومه انها زادت الانفاق على
المدينه بشكل كبير خلال سنوات الاخيره
[موسيقى]
سيدي ابو زيد ما فيهاش طرقات اللي فيها
حتى بنيه تحت تشوف تقدر
تشوف يعني مش مستغلينها الناس كلها تحب
تجي منها البلاد على خاطر ما اعطونا شيء
يعني نموت كل نهار نموت كل نهار نموت كل
نهار نموت
[موسيقى]
يعني خلصت ب 25 دينار مشيت خليت بها دجاجه
يعني
[موسيقى]
بعض الولايات قريبه من السلطه مثلا تونس
بن عروس سوسه كان معدل نوفاك العمومي
حاولي 160 و180 دينار ثانويه وفي الولايات
المهمشه
في حدود 33 36 دينار معناها فيه نسبه
تقريبا
لا يمكن ان يكون هذا صحيح لان الميزانيات
التنميه التي خصصتها
الحكومات بعد الثوره
لولايه سيدي بوزيد مثلا وكذلك
لاربعه عشر ولايه من الولايات الداخل هي
ميزانيه
في الرقم بتاعها تتجاوز مجموع الميزانيات
لايقاع تخصيصها مثلا لولايه سيدي بوزيد
منذ الاستقلال الى سنه 2011
[موسيقى]
في السنوات الاخيره شهدت هذه المناطق
تعطيل لمشاريع تنمويه عديده كانت قد اقرت
كمشروع المنطقه السقويه في اولاد حفوز
ومشروع وحده الفوسفات بالمكناس اضافه
لتوقف مشروع مشفى الجامعي في مدينه سيدي
بوزيد
[تصفيق]
مستشفى الجامعي كان فكره
وجول هنا للرؤساء الثلاثه وما يصيرش من
المشروع هذاك واخر المستشفى
ويزيد البنيه التحتيه كنت تشوفها يعني
مهريه تماما حتى مرافق ما تم حتى شيء شوف
فيها يعني بلسم امشي بفكر تهميش في كل
المجالات
في سيدي بوزيد مؤشر الفقر متعدد الاشكال
يعني بما فيه تعليم والصحه
حوالي 59% اعلى معدل كذلك نسبه السكان همم
الذين يتمتعون بالماء الصالح للشرب
50% من اعلى نسب في الجمهوريه نسبه
الانقطاع دير راسي 21
7% يعني هذه بالنسبه لمحافظه سيدي بوزيد
[موسيقى]
واللي يجمع بين الدول التي كلها هو ذو
الظواهر الظاهره الاولى
تشتغل في منظومات الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه
مغلقه
الجانب الثاني الفرص التي تقدم للناس في
تحسين قدراتهم وكفاءات الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه
من المجموعه
[موسيقى]
رغم التغيرات السياسيه التي شهدتها بعض
الدول العربيه ما تزال معاناه سكان
المناطق المهمه
المركزيه في الاداره كاحد الحلول ليبرز
التساؤل عن امكانيه نجاح الخطط الحكوميه
والمبادرات الاهليه للتخفيف من اثار
الاقصاء ورفع مستوى تنميه تلك المناطق ضمن
منظومه التنميه المحليه
[موسيقى]
الواقعه تقرير الامميه التنميه المتباينه
على اساس المكان او الموقع الجغرافي فشلا
في تحقيق العداله الاقتصاديه او خيانه
للعقد الاجتماعي وتغييره هذا الواقع في
دولنا العربيه خاصه متوسطه ومنخفضه الدخل
بدي مهمه صعبه في الواقع تشير تقارير عده
الى ان المنطقه العربيه التي يقدر عدد
سكانها باكثر من 430 مليون نسمه تشهد
تراجعا في تحقيق اهداف التنميه المستدامه
المتعلقه بالقضاء على الفقر وعدم المساواه
وتسجل احد اعلى مستويات فوارق الدخل في
العالم في عام
2019 مثلا قدرت بنحو 16 نسبه الفقر متعدد
الابعاد في الدول العربيه وهو يشمل
الحرمان الحاد من الصحه والتعليم والنخفاض
مستويات المعيشه وقد صنف نحو 100 و16
مليون عربي صنفوا ضمن الفقراء في 10 دول
عربيه خاصه بعد جائعته كورونا بينما صنف
خمسه 25% من سكان المنطقه العربيه ضمن فئه
المعرضين للفقر ويدفع التهميش والفقر الى
الهجره الى المدن وقد قدرت نسبه سكان
المناطق الحضريه في الدول العربيه بحوالي
تسعه وخمسين بالمئه عام 2019 هذه النسبه
اعلى من مثيلتها على المستوى العالمي
والمقدره بنحو
55% وعلى مستوى الدول الناميه والمقدره
بنحوه سته واربعين في المئه يمثل تنانين
سكان المناطق الحضريه في الواقع يمثل
تحديا تنمويا يلزمه الحكومات العربيه
بالسعيد الى تلبيه طلب المتنانه على البنا
التحتيه الحضاريه وايجاد فرص عمل ويتوقع
ان المنطقه العربيه ستكون بحاجه الى ايج
ما بين 60 مليون الى مئه مليون وظيفه
بحلول العام30 الاخفاق مشاهدين يعني
اضطرابات اجتماعيه والسياسيه
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مجددا المشاهدين الكرام وبضيفينا
الكريمين في هذه الحلقه من باريس الدكتوره
داليا غانم باحثه اولى مقيمه في مركز
الشرق الاوسط ومن عمان الدكتور فارس
بريزات وهو الوزير السابق مدير مركز نماء
للاستشارات الاستراتيجيه نبدا معك دكتور
فارس لطالما كانت معضله حقيقيه المركز
والاطراف
عفوا هذه المناطق المهمه والسؤال حقيقه عن
اسباب ذلك باعتقادك هل هي دائما سوء تسيير
فساد اما ان هناك تحديات حقيقيه منها ما
هو الجغرافي واقتصادي او حتى سياسيه
شكرا سيدتي على الاستضافه انا تقديري ان
الخلل الاساسي
لوجود التهميش هو السياسات العامه التي لا
تاخذ بعين الاعتبار مستويات التنميه
المختلفه في البلد
وايضا عدم القدره على معالجه اولويات
المجتمع سواء كانت اقتصاديه او اجتماعيه
او تنمويه وغيرها
اهم ما في موضوع السياسات العامه هو عندما
تبنى بلا معلومات وبلا بيانات وتكون مبنيه
على انطباعات وليست على معلومات حقيقيه عن
المجتمع وما هي المشاكل التي يعاني منها
ايضا هناك حاله من عدم الملكيه للسياسات
العامه مثلا عندما يكون الشباب مغيبون همم
عن العمليه السياسيه في اي بلد او يكون
مستوى تمثيلها هؤلاء الشباب في النظام
السيا متدني وهم الفئه الاكبر في مجتمعات
العربيه سيبقى هناك خلل اا في معالجه
قضاياهم اولوياتهم وعندما ننطلق ننظر الى
الموضوع من وجهه نظر اعاده توزيع موارد
الدوله واعاده توزيع موارد التنميه نرى
بانه الاساس في هذه المشكله هو عدم وجود
نظام سياسي ديمقراطي ينتج عنه همم قيام
احزاب سياسيه تعبر عن المصالح الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه للمجتمع لا زال في مجتمعاتنا
العربيه بشكل عام هناك
خلل كبير في التمثيل السياسي للمصالح
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه لانه عدم وجود
نظام سياسي ديموقراطي ناضج قادر على همم
ايصال احتياجات الناس الى مستوى السياسات
العامه على مستوى البرلمان وعلى مستوى
الحكومه سيبقى هناك خلل الخلل ان راح في
مناطق عديده تحدثت تحدثتم عنها في
البرنامج مثل في موريتانيا والسودان
واليمن ولكن ايضا وتعنت تونس وهناك مناطق
اخرى كثيره مثلا لم نسمع كلمه اللاجئين
بعد اللاجئين هم احد الم- ال- ال-
المجموعات المهمشه الى حد كبير جدا سواء
كان اللاجئين الفلسطينيين او العراقين او
اليمنيين او السوريين او
او لا
اكبر الدول التي تستقبل هؤلاء على اراضيها
نظل لما يتطلبه ذلك ايضا من مشاريع وموارد
ايضا
لاستقبالها هؤلاء وادماجهم في المجتمع
وغير ذلك يعني يتحول الدكتور داليا
الدكتوره داليا يعني هذه همم الظاهره كما
ذكر دكتور فارس لا تقتصر على النماذج التي
عرضناها في البرنامج للاسف الشديد فقط لكن
هي همم
تكون موجوده في معظم الدول العربيه
والسؤال وفق تشخيص الدكتور فارس هو
السياسات ارجع ذلك للسياسات العامه التي
توضع من قبل الحكومات لماذا لم تنجح لطالم
نسمع عن مشاريع تنمويه للنهوض بهذه
المناطق المهمشه ومنذ الاستقلال في كثير
من الدول العربيه لكن الواقع لا يعكس ذلك
اين الخلل
صحيح صحيح ان العامل هو السياسي
الاسباب سياسيه الانظمه الموجوده في
المنطقه العربيه اليوم لا يمكن ان تنتج
عداله اجتماعيه فهي انظمه استبداديه او
شبه استبداديه ولكن هناك كذلك عامل تاريخي
يرتبط بالعالم بالعامل السياسي اليوم
العمل التاريخ المهم في العادات من الدول
لليوم خاصه في شمال افريقيا التهميش
المناطق هو ارث من الماضي الاستعماري الذي
استمر في ظل الدوله القوميه يعني المستقله
بسبب سوء اختيار السياسات والتحيز
الاقليمي يعني قسمت همم القوه الاستعماريه
انا ذاك هذه البلدان الى مثلا في الجزائر
الى الجزائر المفيده والجزائر غير المفيده
وعامل ذلك في تونس والمغرب غير ذلك وفي
هذه الرؤيه تركزت خطط التنميه في العواصف
في العواصم والمناطق الساحليه عندما حصلت
هذه البلدان على استقلالها اعيد انتاج نفس
النمط من طرف الدوله القوميه ركزت السلطات
المركزيه خطتها التنمويه على المناطق
الساحليه
وتركت والمدن الشماليه وتركت معظم المناطق
الغنيه بالموارد الطبيعيه في الاماكن
المائيه متخلفه همم
علاوه الى ذلك همم بالاجابه الى السؤال
الذي طرحتنه لماذا لم تنجح مثل ما قلت كان
في تركيز السلطات المركزيه خطوطتها
التنمويه على الشمال اول همم خطا الخطا
الثاني اللي هو همم حتى لما تم في مشاريع
تنمويه وانا شفتها في في الحاله الجزائريه
كذلك في الحاله
التونسيه بما انني درست الحدود الجزائريه
التونسيه
نقلت من مدينه تبسه الى مدينه قصرين
حتى لما يتم متابعه المشاريع همم فا هذه
المشاريع ليست متوازنه على الصعيد حتى
المحلي همم
يعني حتى على الصعيد المحلي مثلا لما
بنروح على منطقه مثل تبسه حنرى انه تبسه
متطوره نوعا ما اذا رجعنا الى منطقه
الونزه تخلف اذا رجعنا اكثر الى منطقه
دوروش اكثر تخلف اذا رحنا على الملايه
اللي هي سوق اهراس اكتر التطور همم اذا في
في همم خلل
وكذلك في مشكله مهمه لانه في بعض الاحيان
نفكر انه ما في اموال ولكن في الاموال
ولكن فيها ظاهره الفساد في همم هذه
المشاريع تاتي همم مصحوبه بالتلاعب
السياسي والاحتيال والفساد والعمل على
اسراء بعض الاشخاص القريبين من السلطه
اا ممم لطالما تعاني المجتمعات العربيه
بالفعل كثير من المجتمعات العربيه واعاني
من من ظاهره الفساد التي تقضم هذه الموارد
حتى وان كانت موارد كبيره لا يرى اي اثار
لها للاسف الشديد على المواطن البسيط اعود
للدكتور فارس بريزات والدكتوره داليا قد
اشارت الى نقطه مهمه ويبنيه الدوله
العربيه تهميش همم ربما هذه المناطق هناك
من يرجعه الى طبيعه بنيه الدوله العربيه
التي تشكلت بعد الاستقلال في كثير من
المناطق التي تمثل النخب بشكل او باخر ال-
ال- ال- ال- الموجوده في العواصم وبالتالي
السؤال الى اي مدى هذا الاقصاء او التهميش
لبعض المناطق مرتبطه ربما
بحضورها وتمثيلها ايضا في الحكم بوجود قوه
ضغط تمثلها في المركز وغياب ذلك صحه تعبير
على الهواء مش في ايه المناطق ال- ال-
المهمشه
سيدتي المشكله هي المشكله البنيويه في
بنيه الدوله بشكل اكيد هناك الدوله
الرايعيه والدوله شبه الريعيه في المنطقه
العربيه خصوصا ما بعد فتره الاستقلال ااه
ولم تقم هذه الدول بتقديم النماذج ناجحه
باستثناء بعض دول الخليج التي التحقت بركب
التقدم التنموي مؤخرا خلال 20 عام الماضي
لكن اذا ما نظرنا الى مجمل الدول العربيه
نجد بان هذا النموذج الريعي والشبه
الرايعي همم لم ينجح في خلق تنميه متساويه
ومتكافئه بين المركز والاطراف الحقيقه ما
اشرت اليه بغياب الذين يمثلون هذه المناطق
المهمه سواء كانت مهمشه جغرافيه او بعض
الفئات المهمشه مثل الاقليات او الشباب او
المراه همم او ذوي الاعاقه او ذوي اللون
المخ مثلا في موريتانيا الحراطين او في
اليمن الاقدام هذه المجموعات بقيت الى
وحتى الان على الرغم من حجم الاهتمام همم
فيها على المستوى العالمي كالقليات او
مجموعات ترقيه مهضومه الحقوق او لم تحصل
على حقوق مشابهه او متساويه مع بقيه
المواطنين في هذه الدول لذلك
باعتقاد نعود مره اخرى الى شكل النظام
السياسي والسياسات العامه الناتجه عنه
التي تمكن هؤلاء مثل الاخلاق في العمليه
السياسيه للدفاع عن مصالحهم
لكن ذلك لا ينعكس على شكل مشاريع في هذه
همم المناطق يعني في الاردن مثلا يستخدم
تعبير المناطق ذات الخصوصيه همم التنمويه
بوصف هذه المناطق التي تعاني من الفقر
والبطاله والتاني وقله
التنمويه والسؤال في الواقع ما التحديات
التي واجهت السياسات الحكوميه في تغيير
هذا الوضع باعتقادك
نقص الموارد الماليه التي لم تكن متاحه
بشكل كافي
للموزنات او للحكومات الاردنيه المتعقبه
الشيء الثاني عدم استغلال الموارد
الطبيعيه المتاحه مثل المشاريع التعدين
نحن لغايه الان نعتمد بشكل اساسي على
نموذجين من التعدين الفوسفات والبوتاس
ولكن الارض الاردنيه غنيه جدا بموارد
طبيعيه اخرى وخصوصا المعادن الثمينه
وخصوصا ان الاردن يقع على همم في منطقه
همم حفره انهدام الممتده من من ارتيريا
واثيوبيا الى اعالي غور الاردن الشمالي
وهذه المنطقه على جانبي البحر الاحمر همم
مشهوره بالمعادن مثل الذهب والنحاس وغيرها
الجانب الاخر له علاقه بالمشاريع التنمويه
السياحيه التي ترتبط بالطبيعه باعتقاد هذا
لغايه الان لم
همم
الممكن منه همم ونتامل انه في قادم الايام
يتغير هذا الى وضع اكثر قدره على همم
اخراج الممكنات التنمويه في هذه المناطق
ايضا هناك مشاريع تتعلق بالزراعه
والتكنولوجيا الزراعه هي التي يمكن ان همم
توجه هذه المناطق نحو تنميه متكافئه مع
مراكز المدن ومع المناطق الحضريه لكن يبقى
ايضا انه على الرغم سؤالك الاول على الرغم
من وجود ممثلين لهذه المناطق همم لان
التمثيل هذا لازال يعاني من تشوهات بنيويه
لها علاقه
بالاعتماد ليس فقط على تمثيل المصالح
الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه وانما ايضا هناك
تمثيل همم قبلي عشائري جغرافي جهوي ااا
الطائفي معرقي يعتمد على
ممكنات لتمكين بعض هذه الفئات من الحضور
في مجلس النواب ولكن باعتقادي من وجهه نظر
ديمقراطيه بحته ومن وجهه نظر المساواه
والمواطنه والمساواه امام القانون هذه
جميعا يجب ان تكون حلول مؤقته وليست حلول
دائما همم لكي نصل الى المجتمع الذي
يتساوى فيه المواطنين وايضا تتساوى فيه
الحقوق والواجبات
المشكله عدم العداله في توزيع الفرس اهمال
هذه المناطق له تداعيات كبيره يكبد هذه
الحكومات حكومات هذه الدول خسائر كبيره
كانت لك دراسه ملفته على المناطق الشماليه
الشرقيه في الجزائر مثلا من بين تداعيات
ذلك ان الناس يتجهون الى تدبير امورهم في
نهايه الامر يريدون ان يعيشوا حيث ان تعشت
في هذه المنطقه كما ذكرت دراستك همم
التهريب السلع الذي يستنزف ايضا موارد
الدوله من جهه اخرى وبالتالي السؤال الان
بطريقه همم او بصوره عامه متى دعايات
الاقتصاديه نعم لكن اجتماعيه ايضا
والسياسيه الناتج عن تهميش هذه المناطق
اذا اولا هناك علاقه ما
بين التهميش الجغرافيا في التهميش
الاجتماعي الثقافي الاقتصادي عندما لا
يكون للاشخاص نفس الفرص للذهاب الى
المدرسه للوصول الى المدرسه للحصول على
افضل المعلمين همم هيكون همم تعلم همم
لانهم في تشويها ومن ذلك فرص العمل لا لن
تكون نفسها للجميع على سبيل المثال في
الجزائر كان منطقه مهمه الا وهي منطقه
غنيه
طبيعيه تنتج حوالي اكثر من 400 الف برميل
همم نفط يوميا وهي منطقه وردلاء في منطقه
ورجله التي تعتبر قلب الاقتصاد الجزائري
مع ما لا يقل من
71% بالنسبه
الاحتياق النفسي في حقل حسين سعود اللي هو
على بعد 80 كيلو متر من
المدينه هناك تهميش غير طبيعي في هذه
المنطقه هذا يسبب احباط الناس هذا يسبب
كذلك انه لا يتم توظيف الاشخاص من ورق لا
في شريط في شركات النفط التي لانه هذه
الشركات تفضل توظيف الناس اللي جايين من
الشمال يعني شمال الجزائر يعني الجزائر
العاصمه وهران قسنطينه تلمسان وغير ذلك
وهذا له تداعيات امنيه خطيره لماذا لانه
الاحباط يحلق سيخلق همم عفوا لانه الاحباط
سيخلق حاله غضب هذه الحاله الغضب تؤدي الى
تؤدي بعض الناس اليوم يقولون في ورد لا
نحن محظورين في بلاد البترول ومعهم حق
البعض يتكلم عن استعمار داخلي اذا
نتداعيات هي تداعيات ان كان يعني
كان هنا تداعيات ربما كما ذكرت في المثال
الذي ذكرتيه لكن في مناطق اخرى اين بدايه
همم التونسيه من اين كانت نتيجه لهذا
الضيم والظلم الذي يحثه همم ابناء هذه
المناطق اليس من باب اولى ان يكون هناك
ربما تنبه وتفضل من قبل همم السلطات بانها
يمكن ان تكون مصدرا للقلاقل وبالتالي
ضروره همم ربما همم حل هذه المشاكل
بالضخم مشاريع تنمويه ضمانا للاستقرار
الاجتماع والامني
اكيد اكيد من المفروض
السلطات المحليه عارفه المشكله وهي واعيه
في منطقه مثلا تطاوين في تونس صارت تطاوين
منطقه
لكل العالم يعرفها اليوم لانه فيها مشاكل
امنيه كبيره
ناتجه على على التهميش والاقصاء وغير ذلك
ولكن اظن ان المشكله هي مشكله اموال هناك
اموال وتدخل اموال خليني اعطيك مثال بسيط
اممم
بالنسبه لعام 2019 في منطقه في في الجزائر
مثلت المشتريات العامه في الجزائر اكثر من
20% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي اعلى بكثير
من المتوسط بالنسبه للدول منظمه التعاون
الاقتصادي والتنميه والتي تمثل ما يقارب
12% نحنا في الجزائر تقارب 20% من الناتج
المحلي الاسواق خضع للعمولات الولائيه هي
الاكبر من حيث العدد والممتلكات الماليه
بنسبه 52 و69 يعني كان مصاري بيعطوا
المصاري ولكن تاتي المشاريع التنمويه
مصحوبه بالتلاعب السياسي الفساد والاحتيال
والتبذير ولذلك كفى يتم الهمم يعني بننتهي
في اخر الوضع بمشاريع في بعض الاحيان
منفعه لها ولا تعود في نهايه الامر على
المواطن بالفائده نود ان تبقى معنا
الدكتوره داليا في الواقعنا بدنا نتوقف مع
بعض المشاركات همم القيمه همم احمد محسن
وهو باحث متخصص في العلوم السياسيه
والسياسات العامه اوضح في مشاركه معنا ان
التعامل مع المناطق المهمه
عبر تطوير هذه المناطق وتحسين الخدمات
فيها او عبر النقل الاهالي الى مناطق
جديده كما حدث في التعامل المصري مع
عشوائيات القاهره والمدن شكرا لكنه يحذر
من ان الخيار الثاني قد يؤدي الى اعاده
انتاج التهميش مره اخرى اذا لم توفر
الحكومات فرص عمل ومناخ اجتماعي يتيح
استمرار الاهالي في المناطق الجديده
نتابعنا
وجود الناس في المناطق المهمه في هذه
المنطقه المحدده كان مرتبط بالسياق
اجتماعي واقتصادي هم عايشين من خلاله
بمعنى ان هو في وظيفه هو بيلتحق بها في
مصدر دخل موجود به بغض النظر اذا كان
المصدر الدخل ده قليل ولا همم كثير لكن هو
كان حياته مرتبطه بان هو بيعيش في هذه
المنطقه اللي ممكن له دخل معين من اشخاص
معينين او جهات معينه طب ما احنا بدنا
ننقلهم الى جهه جديده او الى مكان جديد هل
تم تامين نفس هذا مصدر الدخل اللي هم
كانوا معتمرين عليه او مصدر دخل بديل هل
في جهات او مؤسسات ممكن تقدم له فرص عمل
بحيث ان هو همم يقدر ان يعمل ويكسبوته
هنا بتطرح سؤال الاستمراريه والاستدامه
لان احنا لما الناس بتروح بيكون عندها
سكن جديد ملائم لكن مفيش مصدر دخل ما فيش
ما فيش جهات ممكن تساعد على استمرار في
هذا المكان فاحنا في الحقيقه بنحول هذه
المناطق الى مناطق ما فيهاش صيغه
الاستدامه وربما بنساهم بشكل اخر في جعل
حياه هذه الناس اكثر سوءا هذا طبعا مستر
لكن مشاركه اخرى ناخذها الان من المغرب
اين لمس الدكتور الحافظ النويني وهو باحث
في العلوم السياسيه والقانون الدولي حتى
دعايات التهميش وهو البطاله خاصه بين
الشباب الشعر الى تبني الحكومه المغربيه
برامج لمعالجه هذا الجانب لكنها تواجه
عراقيه عند التنفي
الحكومه المغربيه تسعه جاهده للقضاء على
الهشاشه من خلال يعني القضاء على البطاله
داخل وزاره الشباب مثلا هناك برنامج يسمى
المبادره الوطنيه للتنميه البشريه اطلق
سنه 2005 ولكن منذ ذلك الحين الى حد
اللحظه لم يحقق الاهداف المرجو منه ايضا
ثم يعني اطلاق برنامج
العمل الخاص وروح المقاوله داخل الصلاه من
اجل التشجيم على القيام باعمال خاصه
بدعمهم بقروض صغرى ومتوسطه من طرف الابناك
ولكن همم للاسف هذه البرامج دائما يكونوا
اشكاله الاول هو انها على مستوى الواقع
هناك اختلاف وفروقات
يعلن عنه يعني عندما ناتي للتنفي تكون
هناك على قيد
اذا كانت هذه المشاركه من المغرب اعود مره
اخرى للدكتور اييه فارس ونحن نتحدث طبعا
عن تداعيات المشاركه من ضيفنا الكريم من
مصر تحدث عن ان بعض الحلول تخلق مشاكل
بمعنى انه يتم نقل هؤلاء من المدن المكتظه
في بعض الاحيان ايضا من العاصمه مثلا الى
مناطق اخرى لكن ذلك يخلق مشاكل كبيره كذلك
الامر بالنسبه لهؤلاء الذين ينزحون من
المناطق المهمشه الى حواضر المدن يخلقون
واقعا كثير همم جديده همم لا يكون دائما
افضل بالنسبه لهم تقرير الامميه تشيل
لانها اكثر من 60% من سكان العالم العربي
سيقيمون في مناطق حضاريه بعام بحلول عام
2030 ومن هنا السؤال تاثير هذا البعد
باعتقادك اذا استمر الحال على ما هو عليه
سيدتي اولا الدور الحقيقي للدوله هو دور
تمكيني والتمكين يكمن في التعليم والصحه
والبيئه والنقل
والتمكين القطاع الخاص من التوسع
باستثماراته لكي تمكن من تشغيلها هؤلاء في
ظل غياب مثل هذه المنظومه المتكامله
لنمو الذي يتطور الى التنميه
سيتم اعاده خلق هذه المشاكل سواء كانت
بالمشاريع
التنمويه العمرانيه التي يتم انشائها ولا
يتم اخذ بعين الاخذ بعين الاعتبار بانه
هؤلاء ينبغي ان يلتحقوا بوظائف دائمه
ومستدامه في السوق العمل هذا ينتج عنه
مشاكل كثيره جدا منها على سبيل المثال
لانه خلال العشر سنوات الماضيه ارتفعت
نسبه العرب الذين يرغبون بالهجره الى نحو
ثلث العرب الذين تقع اعمارهم همم اكثر من
عام باكثر من 18 سنه لذلك هناك خصوصا بين
الشباب تصل في بعض البلدان العربيه الى
50% وبين الشباب المتعلمين الذين لديهم
بالدرجه الجامعيه الاولى تكون اعلى ااا من
ذلك هذا يعني بان في حاله نفاذ في حاله
نفاذ للقوه البشريه وللعقول من المجتمع
العربي الى مجتمعات اخرى على الاقل هؤلاء
هاجروا على المستوى الدهني والعاطفي
والنفسي حتى لو لم يتمكنوا من الهجره
الفعليه على ارض الواقع وهذا يترك جزء شيء
اخر اللي هو الاغتراب الداخلي داخل
المجتمع همم لا يستطيع ان ينتقل الى دور
المنتج الفاعل ولا يستطيع ايضا ان همم
يتطور
بمهاراته لكي يستجيب الى حاجات سوق العمل
لان لديه درجه جامعيه وينبغي ان يعمل همم
بتخصصه وهذا ايضا همم يعني اخرج لنا مشكله
اخرى وهي التركي الكثيف جدا على التعليم
الاكاديمي على التعليم المهني اليوم في
همم بلد زي المانيا مثلا نسبه التعليم
المهني الى التعليم
الاكاديمي نصف تقريبا بينما في الاردن
حوالي 80% تذهب الى التعليم الاكاديمي
وهذا ينتج عنه بطاله متراكمه لا تستطيع لا
يستطيع الاقتصاد ان يخلق همم فرص عمل تكفي
لهؤلاء لذلك همم
الامر الدكتور فارس يعني ابدا اقسم ما
تبقى من وقت بينك وبين دكتور داليه في
عوجا الدكتوره داليا لو تكرمتي ماذا عن
الحلول ما الذي يمكن ان يطرح خطب مهم
تشخيص المشكله لكن ما الحلول اللانجع
باعتقادك همم كتصور او طرح اشكال جديده
للتنميه المحليه في الدول العربيه التي
تعاني من مركزيه شديده هي التي تقف في
كثير الاحيان عائقا امام همم وص الحلول
الى الاطراف
الحلول الصعبه
في في الدقائق الاخيره همم
الاهم هو ان اليوم عندما لا يستطيع مثل ما
قلت انت الناس الاعتماد على الدوله
سيعتمدون على انفسهم في بعض المناطق اليوم
الحدوديه في المغرب العربي من 70% من
الشباب يعملون في التهريب لا يعملون في
التهريب لانه يريدون المال السهل كما يظن
البعض ولكن لان ليس لهم افق على الاطلاق
وهذا شيء خطير يعني سنرى انكسارات في
العديد من هذه المناطق المهمه كان هو
الحال في السنوات الاخيره في العديد من
هذه المناطق من سيدي بوزيد طاطا وين ورقله
وغيرها ولا قدر اينما ماذا يحدث عندما
نرى شباب هاجروا الى همم الى داعش للقتال
مع داعش في سوريا والعراق ليس لانهم كانوا
مقتنعون بواجبهم في رفع رايه الله لا ولكن
لانهم لان هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه
رواتب وعادتهم بمستقبل افضل بمنظور وظيفي
وغير ذلك التي لم تستطع دوم ان تعبدوا نعم
دكتوره داليا اعتذر منك اتحول دكتور فارس
في الدقيقه الاخيره تصورك لما يمكن ان
يشكل حلا لهذه المعضله
وتمكين القطاع الخاص لكي يتمكن من انشاء
المشاريع
الاستثماريه والتنمويه في هذه البلدان
لانه بدون ذلك الدوله لا تستطيع ان تتحمل
اعباء تشغيل بلا عمل يعني وظائف لا غير
منتجه والتوظيف هو ليس من مهمه الدوله
مهمه الدوله ايه التمكين من خلال تعليم
والصحه والبيئه والنقل هذه هي الوظائف
الرئيسيه التي يجب ان تركز عليها ويفتح
المجال للقطاع الخاص لكي يكون بواجبه
لردم هذه الفجوه بين القوه البشريه
وامكانيات الاقتصاد اشكرك
مدير مركزنا للاستشارات الاستراتيجيه كنت
معنا من عمان
شكرا
هذا من برنامج القصيده نعود ونلقاكم باذن
الله مع بقيه بقصه جديده الاثنين القادم
[موسيقى]